you want to pay our respects to their
unlikely friendship here's Adam and
Blake the way they were that's like
looking in the mirror right at them what
is that on your head
exactly I'm not saying a word I don't it
look like you're wearing a pair of jeans
that buttons up at your neck I reached
out to Blake a couple months ago said
hey man I want to do a song it's about
time and he didn't even write it back
well there'd be I'm around to do it
again did you hear what I said
hear what I just said my rivalry with
Adam is still going don't raise your
hand you're not in fourth grade everyone
always asks if it's real if the things
we say or premeditated or scripted or if
we have the strategy we really don't yes
the voice is known for Adam and Blake's
bromance but looking back at season one
it seems the producers actually tried to
create a spark between Adam and
Christina Aguilera Christina Aguilera is
one of the best singers on earth but I
can assure you that she is not one of
the best coaches Blake was actually a
big softie and he had zero competitive
edge as soon as the show was over I came
up and I hugged Adam and I said you know
what buddy the right person won don't
you wish that since he's dressed like a
mom he would actually sound like
by season three these guys were besties
what Adam told Blake today you're my
brother for life okay stop stop now it's
groping now it's groping now it's
groping I love Blake Sheldon a lot yeah
he's a wonderful human being and I can't
say enough nice things about him that
was being nice really if I was being
honest douchebag
[Music]